last night when
i looked up and nate sutfield was emma
and the eagles were blatantly tanking
you know what i said to myself
i can't wait to hear what michael holly
has to say about this tomorrow
because as you know the tension of
tanking
turns me on there nobody's neutral on
tanking everybody
everybody's going to take on tanking
yeah and you and i
went at it like we do we're going to add
on a lot of things
but on few topics like we do
the jets and that taking conversation
that was going on
throughout the season especially late in
the year so i know how much it just
it hurts you to your core the very very
suggestion that an organization
would intentionally tank for drought an
organization
players and coaches players
organizations everybody
organizations so that said how did you
feel
and how did you feel now that you had a
chance to sleep on it and process it
how did you feel when you saw the eagles
pull that act last night
that's a great question because this is
how i i felt at the time and i feel this
way
even more now and that is confused
i'm confused by doug peterson
if he was tanking you don't even know
how to tank the right way
look if you're going to tank that you're
going to do that go into that game mike
and say
all right i'm just going to let
everybody know that jalen hurts will not
be starting game 16.
i'm gonna turn it over to setfield he's
been here for four years
um we're not going to the playoffs we
think we can be competitive with sudfeld
i just want to see what i have there
then it's obvious
that you don't you don't you're not
trying to win the game and you let
people know that beforehand
but when you start a game and you're
down by three points
and you take jalen hurts out of the game
and your logic for putting sutfelt in
the game
is well i thought he deserved it after
four years deserves got nothing to do
with it what are you talking about
he deserves it because he's been here
for four years i don't understand that
you're not playing to win no
he's he's playing the win next year
or he's playing to win the sixth pick
and this is why this is why i'm also
confused about tanking
because nobody really cares about you
tanking the organization doesn't care
about
you tanking personally okay
everybody wanted adam gates to tank they
won two games
they look they had gotten the number one
pick he was gonna be fired
they lost the number one pick he got
fired
doug marone hey thanks for tanking bye
so the organization is not gonna scratch
your back they're not gonna hook you up
with some contract extension because
you have carried out their plans so
that's not a reason to do it
you lose the respect of every single
player in that locker room probably even
including
sud phil if you tank if you do what what
doug peterson did last night so that's
what i'm saying i'm confused there's
really no logic for
what he did i don't understand what he
was trying to accomplish
yeah i gotta say i've been watching
football for a long time
i've never seen tanking
for the sixth pick i've never seen
tanking from now that's a good way of
saying this
i've seen i've seen taken for number one
not before even number two
you know top two but six from nine to
six
i mean look i think jamar chase would
look great in the eagles uniform but is
there that big of a difference between
jamar chase and devonta
smith i i don't i guess
i guess i mean it uh
good and we're just running and with
this run on quarterbacks mike
he might be there at six anyway he might
be there at nine anyway we don't wanna
well that's my thing so it's a couple of
things michael there's a couple of
things well you're taking
if you're gonna tank don't you have to
tank with somebody in mind
you're tanking for something that that's
what that's why that's why you've never
seen it that's why it's usually number
one or number two
so that's the thing that's why you've
never seen it it's a combination of
things it's a convergence it's
it's prime time it's the last game of
the season
it's a rivalry game a division game
uh everybody's watching as opposed to
you know nobody paying much attention
because it's an earlier game and it's
not nationally televised
um the playoffs were at stake
and it was just it was the most blatant
act that i can remember
you know i i knew something was up
when carson wentz was inactive i was
like
i was like did he get punished because i
saw the report
from i think it was from uh from mort
yesterday from chris mortensen
that he's going to ask for a trade
because his relationship is so damaged
with doug peterson's like damn dude
i wonder why and deactivate him yeah
yeah right i wonder
i wonder why that's not working out yeah
so i was like what's up with that so
it was kind of the writing was on the
wall there when sun fell was up
and you're right there's nothing to
evaluate about nate sutfield
the person you wanted to evaluate in
that situation should have been jalen
hurts
because if you have a decision to make
in the off-season
you need to see if jalen hurts there you
go he wasn't throwing the ball very well
can he pull out that victory can they
can you go into the off-season
with some positivity around jalen hurts
as you try to figure out what to do with
hurts and wentz
so it's like you have one problem and
you compounded it
by compromising your credibility not
just within your locker room
but also quite honestly with your fan
base so michael let me let me
explain this to you because i don't want
you to i don't want you to think i'm
being inconsistent here
because you know how passionate i was
about there being a difference about the
jets
and i was a process truther
sam henke was my guy i trusted the
process
with the sixers and so
i get that they didn't have anything to
play for but there isn't a uniform
methodology to tanking
i think tanking there's there's a
different way to approach
tanking depending on your circumstances
and depending on the organization
if you're the new york jets and you
don't have a franchise quarterback or
you don't believe you have a franchise
quarterback
and there's a generational quarterback
available with the number one pick
you winning against the rams and then
the browns
to cost yourself a chance at the person
who's considered to be a generational
quarterback
that while it matters for the players
and it matters for the coaches
that's not something that helps you in
the long run
i guess
later that there may be another
years now we oh don't you dare
to head over don't you dare oh don't you
dare don't you start 20 21 like this
don't you start 20 21. did you like it
don't be like no hold up no sit away
don't bring up
i should not even let you interject just
now because don't bring up last derailed
it
and messed up my train of thought by by
spewing that
oh yeah i'm bringing up last year number
one your guy
is zach wilson so you need to stick with
zach wilson that's number one okay
number two i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
back to the eagles in a second but
you're gonna get this work
number two okay i will i distinctly
recall
distinctly recall begging
gary i begged gary carter
and courtney gustafson i said guys i
need this hype video
for ohio state going into the season
because my akron ohio brother is going
to be
super excited to see this here from
akron
hashtag i played it and you were such a
like a
a a wet blanket you were so like
yeah whatever yeah yeah whatever cuz you
didn't even want him to play this year
so you don't have to claim justin you
don't get to claim justin fields for two
or two fronts
you're a zack wilson guy and you are not
an ohio state buckeye this year you
don't get to claim justin fields and you
don't get to know him
no i don't worry i'm so refreshed i get
to do that i'm so thankful you've
already established it so
grateful to him for 2020 i'm the one
telling you about fields all year you
ain't having to say about him
my glasses are different this year
i cannot believe you to my o-h or hell
no
i don't get to o-h on no you don't get
to do that
anyway what was i saying anyway you
talking about philadelphia and you're
talking about the various
i got i got you i told you i just took
it from you okay right back
and i and i was thinking that you were
talking there
i was like michael smith really needs to
write a book
on tank on the process because you're
doing a very good job of giving a
scientific
breakthrough i guess not equal well
and this is why this is why it stung so
badly last night because there was
something
about it was almost like there was an
innocence loss like tanking
is is something for fans to talk about
it's a way for fans of teams that have
no hope
to find hope it's like oh there's a
great draft prospect coming out
or two and it's like oh you know we're
not going anywhere
hey we can root for our team to be bad
because the future is bright
and so that's why it's something that we
speculate about
you know we we debate we discuss but
nobody ever really
talks about fight club you know nobody
ever really
actually condones or or or or validates
the the the fact that people tank and
usually when people
tank and it happens a lot but it's for
competitive reasons like okay
hey we're going to rest because we don't
have a buy so we're going to wrest week
17
or exactly we actually do have a better
match up you've seen it firsthand we do
have a better matchup
we want a different seating because of
the path to the playoffs
that's still for a competitive advantage
so that's not quite the same
as like you said and i'll give it to you
you're down by three and you've tried to
win the game and all of a sudden you
just pulled the plug
that just something it just i told you i
believe in sometimes doing the wrong
thing for the right reasons but they
went about this right wrong way
and you know and that's why that's why
mike and i i heard
ron rivera today say oh i'm not going to
apologize for winning which nobody's
asking you to i don't think so
don't apologize for winning and if
people if giants fans are saying that
let's face it i know you beat the
washington football team twice but
those were that that's a third of your
wins right there you you won six games
okay you know win your games win more
games and you're not in this position
uh begging to be a six and
[Music]
seven you know like you shouldn't be
relying on another team
we're gonna get you into the playoffs
well but but but here's the thing though
michael
okay the eagles improved their draft
stock by by three slots
so they felt like there was a it was a
it was a means to an end it felt like it
was worthwhile
but at what cost like what did it cost
you
and it's not that they necessarily owed
directly the giants anything
by the way i don't think that happened
what's that i don't think
i don't think that's why i'm saying i'm
confused
he didn't take i don't think they tanked
why would you do that to go from nine to
six why would you do that
i don't think i don't think doug
peterson did that
did he so he screwed up well but i don't
but i don't know what his logic if
that's the logic
what does he get out of it did they
promise him a contract extension
were they gonna fire i mean he he made
that he's made the playoffs several
years in a row so i don't think they
were going to fire him even though there
was some speculation so what about a
meeting
yeah but i think i think if anything it
shows that he's in lockstep with the
organization
um it's actually a sign of job security
quite honestly
but okay but i'll get to that though so
yeah you have job security
but what i'm saying is as an
organization you improve your draft slot
by three
by your draft place by three slots yeah
but at what cost
because there's no real coming back from
this like
you know that that team built up so much
good will by finally breaking through
winning the super bowl a couple of years
ago
and i'm not saying that this this
cancels that out i'm not saying this is
the this is the
you know the polar opposite of it but
nothing cancel it out for it
it does some damage it does some damage
to their
their reputation i know there are some
sophisticated fans who are like
hey this is great we got a higher draft
slot we had nothing to play for
who cares but i think there are other
fans who that just didn't sit well with
them because
they owe it to the game and by extension
michael this is going back to why i
disagree with you would come to the
giants
if you owe it to yourselves as
professionals to see that game through
and i'm with you if you were gonna it
may have felt differently
had they gone into it with a clearer
intent but you owe it to yourselves as
professionals
and competitors to see that game through
you don't want to go to yourselves you
owe it to the game
the integrity of the game okay the
integrity of the game
would have gotten the giants in the
playoffs so you're right
giants well hold on should have handled
their own business
but if the okay legals actually play
that game and maybe win it then the
giants do get in
so i understand them feeling some kind
of way on that phone but wait a minute
see
and this is what i don't understand all
right i'm not concerned more than you
already were
this is what no no you didn't there's a
great breakdown i'm glad you you know
you you told us everything we need to
know about tanking
all right the difference but this is
something i this
is one thing i have a problem doing when
i hear people
say these things if
that the if then thing okay all right
if doug peterson had left jalen hurts in
the game
then philadelphia would have won no oh
no that's not going to give him that's
not a given that's not right right
so you're saying you took the giants you
crossed the giants a spot in the
playoffs
no you didn't what you did no it's not
the lesson
what you did was lessen their chances of
getting this it's not no
michael i don't i don't know what would
have happened because
here's the other thing but but everybody
would feel better if they would have
played it out
like like the way the game started and
if washington wins
that's fine everybody you know it is
what it is
you know giants you left it up to the
eagles the eagles didn't come through
but for them to concede was an affront
to
everybody's competitive instincts and
it's why you it's why you were so
you went at me so hard at the mirror's
suggestion
because remember i told you when greg
williams called that zero blitz against
the raiders
i'm like you thought it was the only
thing i could think of was that it was a
tank because that was the dumbest play
call i've ever seen
until last night i was like that's the
dumbest thing i've ever seen and michael
you got offended to your core
yeah at the idea that an organization
would not compete
and so for them to do that last night i
just wonder at what cost
long term both in the locker room in the
community within the family
then maybe nobody remembers it when they
get jamar chase and it doesn't matter i
don't know but it just
it doesn't feel right in the moment it's
not of them
it's a him the philadelphia eagles will
be fine in the community
uh owner jeffrey laurie roseman they'll
be great they'll be great
yeah i don't mean the franchise in
perpetuity not leadership peterson
and howie roseman howie roseman and doug
peterson right now by peterson i don't
know
peterson especially if they're going to
be able to live this down
because peterson won't be able to live
it down because a lot of players
they know especially the veteran players
they understand the whole dynamic
uh between the front office and the
locker room
and the coach is kind of like the middle
manager he's got to have his foot in
both worlds
so they could understand how howie
roseman or any general manager would go
to a coach and say
probably best is if if we don't win this
game
but then they want that coach to stand
up for him and be like no
i can't do that i'll take the loss i'll
take the loss
i'll take the win and take the personal
loss
and i will come out i will give a press
conference why didn't it work out i'll
tell the story because they wanted me to
do something
that i didn't want to do my coaches have
been fired for less
there have been coaches who have been
fired because they refused to change
their offensive coordinator or d
coordinator or
fire a special teams coach or
linebackers coach
coaches say no wait a minute i'm not
going to let you do that i'm not going
to let you
you're infiltrating the locker room a
little bit too much i'm not going to let
you do that so i think doug peterson let
that happen
uh and i think i think he is absolutely
done
in philadelphia uh when it when it comes
to his credibility
but you know what he could have said
yesterday i'll say this quickly
um credibility in the community in both
yeah oh yeah he's done he's not in
philadelphia he had no credibility no
because everybody knows he's basically
just he's basically just playing on the
string
how can jalen hurts listen to him
anymore
yeah the look on jail and her carson
wentz already can't stand questions
yeah he's lost carson wins he lost jalen
hurts last night
he probably lost some veterans in the
locker room last night he still got
howard roseman
still got the owner maybe um but the
players
you can't change the entire team even if
you you turn over a third of the team
you're still guys who remember what
happened who know what the real story is
it's like it's just a bad look i tossed
and turned last night
because i was so excited to talk about
this and so conflicted
you say confused i said conflicted
because you know i'm always down
for the greater good yeah look at jimmy
jaylen hurts it i mean that's like it's
pr he became a meme it's priceless
it's like but he could have this is how
this is how
doug peterson could have saved it with
his storytelling
post game there's a really good occasion
to make right
he can say look i took him out
because sure he had those two touchdowns
but he wasn't playing great and i didn't
like
i didn't like the look in his eye he
could have take tank to make it made it
like an
anecdotal thing there's just something
about i had a feeling in my gut
so i wanted it we bought we got
we're up against the break but i gotta i
gotta say nice try i appreciate you
trying to salvage him
nice not all that wouldn't work here not
only are we up against the break
we over the break well barely i got
three twenty one um
he number one he insulted our
intelligence by saying he was coaching
to win
because you don't put nate sutfield in
if you're trying to win that's number
one yeah number two
here's here's where it gets interesting
if you had nothing to really play for
then let the kid play through it you
know like you have a decision to make
this off season
that's going to alter the course of your
of your your future
at the quarterback position and you got
a rookie quarterback who yeah he's not
playing well
you pull him for nate sunfield who does
that help
so he couldn't he couldn't have
explained his way out of it he did worse
by insulting our intelligence and saying
he was coaching to win because he
clearly wasn't
or at least not this year he's coaching
a win down the road hey thanks for
watching brother from another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m
eastern time on peacock appreciate you